pat on vient 3g vous qu'il y ait de
pâques capuche le vôtre haut du corps
comptait bien sur vos droits
[Musique]
quelle belle histoire que j'ai beau
mouchoirs non mouchoirs s'il vous plaît
naturellement bien je ne fais attention
à moi mon dire que les gens disent prêts
à offrir la lune le faut vraiment mouche
[Musique]
merveilleux qu'est ce qui se passe ici
pâtasse prof tab élevé seule quelle
malchance mais pleure pas on en achètera
d'autres hein on fêtera d'autres vers
d'autres assiettes
ce n'est pas vous qui voyez ça pour moi
mais si nous n'aime pas ces six ans tu
aimes tu les auras les assiettes vois tu
me parles d'un siège comme de par de
grandes choses si vous m'aimez pouvait
le mois comment décrocher - la lune la
lune la lune de là haut
oui mais c'est impossible
bah il le fait bien le voile dans mon
livre si vous m'aimez décrocher mois la
lune ne veux pas d'autre chose
zi la lune comme je joue bien la balle
je suis sûr que pâte à tarte doit verser
quelques larmes
tata cloud tu en fais une tête pâte à
tarte eux pleurent j'en étais certaine
c'est parce que je joue trop bien du
piano mais non elle dit qu'on ne
l'aiment pas vraiment je vais lui
prouver le contraire que c'est parce
qu'elle veut mais si mais si
tiens ma petite patate a choisi ce que
tu veux le veulent a eu rien la lune
[Musique]
ouais
à
[Musique]
elle travaille je suis mort de fatigue
attendu que fais-tu avec ce filet à
papillons jeu se rattrape la lune pour
papa part tu ne te fatigue pas j'en ai
une bien
demain
[Musique]
oh
m
patate up bien vite nous avons attrapé
la lune
[Musique]
tu voulais la lune
la voilà où cela ou pas merveilleux un
bon droit à une élégance et parlons gens
de talent une je te promets de ne plus
de la demande et à l'uil j'ai trop
dangereux
ah bah tant mieux par contre
si je pouvais avoir une étoile
[Musique]